[Music]
on this tuesday night limiting social
contacts
to stop the spread the message being
repeated across this country as covet
spreads through communities
the situation now is just as severe if
not maybe
even worse compared to what we endured
in the springtime critical condition
some bar and restaurant owners calling
for life support
out of line one province's black friday
warning for big box stores enticing
crowds of bargain hunters
this is irresponsible and why manitoba's
hiring a private company to enforce
restrictions
and a little help from a friend the
world's leading primatologist joins the
fight
to keep elephants and apes out of
captivity in canada
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as winter approaches and coveted case
numbers creep up there is one message
that canadians need to hear over and
over again
limit your social contacts it worked in
the first wave
and it is essential now across canada
with the exception of the atlantic
bubble case numbers are rising
fast even in nunavut which until a few
weeks ago had no infections
there's now a spike in the last 24 hours
34 more people tested positive there
bringing the total case number in
nunavut to 60.
starting tomorrow the territory enters
two weeks of tough
new restrictions here is the nationwide
picture based on population
manitoba still has the most active cases
per capita
512 for every 100 000 people
the second worst is alberta followed by
quebec
and british columbia with the curve
bending sharply upward canada's top
doctor warns
hospitals in some regions could soon be
overwhelmed
in the last week the national test
positivity rate hit 6.6 percent
that means nearly seven percent of
everyone who got a test in canada
received a positive result
some provinces are now considering
whether to extend the school winter
break to try to curb the spread
in some regions even more drastic
measures may be needed
before that if people don't follow
public health advice
our messaging has been quite clear stay
home
leaving only for essential reasons it is
these small
yet essential efforts like staying home
when we're ill
not having social gatherings we need
everybody who can wear a mask to wear a
mask in
indoor public places stop making excuses
because you don't feel like wearing a
mask
abigail beeman has more on the public
health messaging and the criticism in
some regions that
not enough is being done we all need
to double down to get this second wave
under control
a stark prime ministerial warning
targeted at young people
it could leave you with heart and lung
issues
or it could cost you your life while the
national messaging for
everyone remains the same masks distance
limit contacts every effort you make
matters
as much as you can limit errands and
outings just the essentials
and i know it's hard to hear the same
guidance over and over
canada's top doctors admit kovit 19
fatigue
presents a challenge how do we get
people to to understand appreciate that
the situation now is
just as severe if not maybe even worse
compared to what we endured in the
spring
while critics call for more action why
is no one doing anything i mean what is
it going to take
we have record cases we have a death
toll that's mounting
the confusion out there is massive those
in harder hit zones
are looking at stronger measures several
provinces now considering
a school winter break extension though
the messaging in ontario isn't clear
i'm seriously looking at solutions that
may include
some period out of class i just don't
don't want to
jump the gun here and say you know be
prepared it may not happen
there really is shared responsibility dr
isaac vogosh sees the responsibility for
coven 19 control
as threefold between government
individuals
and businesses we certainly have some
things under our control
we should not be going into our
neighbor's home for
house parties we should not be gathering
in large groups
here in ottawa officials stress
decisions are best made at the local and
provincial levels because the situation
is so
different across the country as an
example dr new said
a national lockdown wouldn't make sense
for atlantic canada
or parts of the north but he did offer
one piece of news applicable
to all canadians he said tentatively
he's hopeful
most canadians could be vaccinated by
the end of next year
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the virus is spreading so fast in
manitoba the test positivity rate there
is now 13.6 percent
and hospital admissions which are a
lagging indicator keep rising
30 people under the age of 50 are in the
hospital with covid19 now yet
some people are still ignoring public
health rules as brittany greenslade
reports
manitoba has hired a private security
firm to enforce them
bed by bed winnipeg's critical care
units are filling up
and top health officials are painting a
grim picture the projections are not
looking good like if we had a worst case
scenario it feels like
this would be it there's been more than
40 deaths in the past four days
the province's latest and youngest
victim a woman
in her 30's no one is immune from this
virus
no one is immune from a severe outcome
from this virus
but the province's top doctor fears many
are not paying attention
mall parking lots remain full and some
non-essential businesses
have looked for loopholes to remain open
even while the province
is in lockdown look at our numbers we're
not all doing the right thing
this is irresponsible
right we can't accept this we're in code
red
in winnipeg right now we have people
dying every day the premier is promising
a further crackdown on those who are
breaking the rules
the province has now hired a trained
private security firm
to help with enforcement there are going
to be
consequences as there have been
increasingly
for those who disregard public health
orders
and in so doing put themselves and put
others in danger
[Applause]
it comes on the heels of an anti-mask
rally held saturday just outside the
city
the rcmp didn't hand out a single ticket
but the premier says those fines
are in the mail in some cases he says
charges are currently being worked on
we have to do more to deter oddball
behavior
unacceptable behavior that endangers us
and endangers one another
and that's exactly what we're doing the
province says further gathering size
limitations and a curfew are not off the
table
it's also considering an extended school
christmas break
after the holidays to try to keep the
virus at bay
brittany greenslade global news winnipeg
british columbia has reported a record
number of daily new cases in the last 24
hours 717
people in bc tested positive and 11 more
people died
the message in bc is the same as
everywhere else limit social
interactions
and avoid non-essential travel in
alberta community spread is driving
exponential growth of the virus
773 new cases were recorded there today
along with five deaths icu wards are
filling up fast and the source of many
infections is a mystery
alberta's coveted 19 app has failed the
province revealed that app has only
traced about
20 cases in six months despite pleas to
impose
tough restrictions premier jason kenney
keeps resisting
saying he needs to protect the economy
though as heather urex west reports it's
the economy that could take a big hit
if the virus isn't brought under control
it has been a confusing few days for
this calgary business
when the province announced new
restrictions last week owner kyle
shufelt was told
gymnastics clubs were exempt but on
monday
he was told they'd have to close after
all it was
literally like a freight train hitting
all of us a lot of the
the anxiety and frustration right now
comes from the fact that you're seeing
around the country these temporary
closures
that continue to be extended we have
entered
an exponential growth period and
that is of course deeply concerning dr
dina hinshaw says if last week's
moderate measures are not enough to slow
the spread
more restrictions will follow though so
far there has been no mention of what
those restrictions could look like
or how long they would last right now
the best course of action both for
public health
and for the economy is to get the virus
under control economist trevor toombs
says lockdowns are painful for
businesses in the short term
but not taking strong enough measures to
control the virus has economic
consequences too
as the pandemic grows larger and people
will just
naturally on their own avoid these type
of activities
and that comes with a large economic
cost
as well you've got the economy tanking
you've got customers afraid to leave
their homes
you've got businesses disrupted you have
distribution disrupted
janine norman says the uncertainty has
been crippling
after being forced to close her business
in the spring she's prepared for the
possibility of
another shutdown she teamed up with two
dozen other small businesses in calgary
and they've moved online this helps and
gives us
you know one more way to reach our
customers if they're not able to come
into our stores
we can certainly get to them now but
going online isn't an option for all
shufelt can only wait for the province's
next move and hope
for the best if we're all in this
together we really need to be
all in this together and that's not
happening right now
heather your ex-west global news calgary
protecting lives and livelihoods is the
balance every political leader is
striving for
keeping businesses open while telling
everyone to stay home is just one of the
contradictory messages
yesterday ontario's top doctor said the
province could be in the green zone by
christmas
today the health minister said that's
overly optimistic
we are very hopeful that all of ontario
will be in a green situation before the
holidays
but i don't think it's something that we
can count on at this point
christmas is just five weeks away and
the lead-up to it is usually one of the
busiest times for businesses including
restaurants and bars
as eric sorenson reports they're finding
it hard to find optimism this year
papa's grill had been around for 33
years till covet 19.
new york cafe is gone old nick closed
the office pub operated in toronto's
entertainment district for nine years
but the owner says he didn't get a rent
subsidy from the landlord and with so
little business
had to shut down we were paying closer
to thirty thousand dollars a month
right so you know good enough food
for food to pay that amount of rent last
summer restaurants were making a
comeback
they'd invested millions in safe
protocols we're super glad that we can
get back up and running
staff at the green eggplant restarted
limited indoor service and expanded
patios gave them a boost
fast forward three months and a double
whammy the weather has all but shut down
outdoor service and covid restrictions
have sealed off indoor dining
probably like dropped down 90 it's
really really good
it's not busy at all small independent
restaurants give communities character
they've been a bulwark against the big
box economy but the pandemic is killing
the little guy
and with it an estimated 200 000 jobs
across the country
the mood is one of you know devastation
and frustration
local watering holes you know represent
a significant part of the culture of of
the downtowns
you know of all towns and cities across
the country restaurant canada has asked
the ontario government to strike a task
force
to collaborate to subsidize struggling
owners and to show that restaurants are
actually
safe places to gather we spent
significant dollars
on various different forms of ppe to
make sure that when folks come to our
restrooms
they are safe and so too our staff and
ourselves
i hear them loud and clear these folks
are struggling they're just trying to
get
get ahead but after i heard the 6500
per day potentially that scares everyone
the premier says he has to follow public
health guidelines
restaurant canada says ten thousand
locations have closed so far
and with a combined wave of covet and
cold weather
another forty thousand may not last much
longer can the business keep going
through the winter
i don't know i it's very hard to say i
hope so
but right now it doesn't seem like it
eric sorensen global news
toronto there appear to be
cracks forming in the atlantic bubble
after months of low case numbers
officials in nova scotia now say there's
evidence of community spread
seven recent cases have no links to
travel and the province's top doctor is
urging people
to be vigilant this is very concerning
and an
important turn of events for us here in
nova scotia i firmly believe we are
still at a point where we can
control the covert path that we follow
but it depends on what we all do
together
and in saskatchewan officials are
imposing new restrictions as part of
what they're calling a one-month
slowdown and we are now strongly
recommending
that only members of your immediate
household be allowed in your home
the province is suspending visits to
long-term care facilities with a few
exceptions and mass are now
mandatory in public spaces province-wide
in saskatchewan
failure of leadership coming up what
went wrong inside the rcmp's
national intelligence center
there is scathing criticism of the rcmp
tonight the federal information
commissioner says
the rcmp's inability to respond to
access to information requests
on time has reached a critical point and
needs intervention
the commissioner launched a special
investigation into the rcmp last year
for repeated and systemic violations of
the access to information act
today that report was tabled in the
house of commons in it caroline maynard
calls for an urgent change of course she
made 15 recommendations and says the
situation at the rcmp is critical
and may soon be past the point of no
return unless senior leaders within the
organization take
action immediately the rcmp had more
than 9
000 active requests for information
during the fiscal year that ended march
31st
2020 it managed to close 54
of those that's the lowest rate of any
major federal department
the government-wide closure rate is 83
percent
today's report noted that while the rcmp
asserts it has implemented many
strategies to improve response times
under the act
the strategies implemented to date have
failed to improve the rcmp's
performance global news has uncovered
exclusive new details about an
independent probe involving a suspected
mole in the rcmp
cameron ordis a former high-ranking
civilian intelligence official
is accused of leaking government secrets
and preparing to share other classified
information
as mercedes-stevenson reports an
independent review ordered by the force
found senior leaders within the rcmp
failed to effectively deal with
allegations about ordis's pattern of
behavior
towards employees and the entire episode
has had a serious impact on canada's
national security
the rcmp had big plans to become a
global intelligence player
taking canada to the next level with a
secretive intelligence capability
that would use highly classified
information from spies
working their sources and intercepting
communications and intelligence around
the world
in 2016 cameron ortis was hand-picked to
lead the mountie's national intelligence
coordination center
his role included setting up so-called
high side intelligence
highly classified information usually
gleaned from allies
but there were signs of trouble early on
just months in
employees were complaining to rcmp
leadership that orders
systematically targeted them dismissing
their work as
garbage global news obtained key
portions of an internal report
prepared by former rcmp assistant
commissioner
alfons mcneil tasked with looking into
the employee's allegations
mcneil doesn't mince his words on what
he found
mcneal describes the top brass
unwillingness to act
as a failure in leadership there were so
many red flags
said one employee we were ignored
completely because of what senior
management thought
said another mcneil heard that an old
boys club
including former commissioner bob
paulson shielded orders from complaints
halsen has denied those allegations in
the past but did not respond to a global
news request for comment
on the mcneil report the report also
says ortiz and rcmp leadership
dismissed employee complaints as staff
upset
with major organizational changes being
introduced
jessica davis a former csis analyst says
that scenario is especially concerning
probably would have enabled him to
engage in some of the alleged criminal
activities for a much longer period of
time without
any any suspicions being levied against
him on that front commissioner brenda
lucky has defended the forces response
once the rcmp became aware of the
alleged activities
we worked with partners to take
immediate steps
to safeguard the information but davis
says the order's case
has damaged the mountie's international
reputation mr ordis's arrest
certainly dealt a significant blow to
the rcmp and that organization
specifically
if that organization was establishing
relationships and trust
in terms of partnerships with other law
enforcement
intelligence functions that would have
been seriously eroded by his arrest
a national security source close to the
investigation told global news
the kind of behaviors orders allegedly
exhibited
are considered classic warning signs of
someone who is at high risk to become
an insider threat but the rcmp brass did
not
effectively address the problem donna
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
ahead the storms just keep coming
hurricane iota hammers
central america
a humanitarian crisis is unfolding in
central america tonight honduras is
being hammered by
powerful winds hurricane iota made
landfall in nicaragua
and torrential rain has triggered flash
flooding and landslides
as crystal gamansing reports the storm
is the second powerful hurricane
to hit that stretch of coastline in two
weeks
families are huddling in shelter for
safety
the destruction across northeastern
nicaragua is devastating
you know what hurricanes are like says
this woman it doesn't cause chaos in
just one
town hurricane iota the strongest to
make landfall this season
hit late monday night it registered as a
category 4
storm packing sustained wind speeds of
up to 249
kilometers per hour it tore roofs from
homes and led to widespread flooding
it hit virtually the same region of
central america
still reeling from hurricane edda which
struck
just 13 days ago and the threat
isn't over forecasters anticipate nearly
a meter of rain will fall this week
it's record breaking in every sense of
the world
we are currently with iota on the 30th
named tropical storm of the atlantic
hurricane season
canadian aid agencies such as oxfam and
plant international
operating in the region say the need for
assistance
will be great all of this is happening
on a backdrop
of an already active drought and food
insecurity situation
as well as a time when we're seeing
surges in covid19 cases
we need clothes
that's something really important water
and also basic reconstruction materials
for
for houses plant international's office
in billwe in the north was used to
shelter people at the height of the
storm right now
safe accommodations especially for
children
food and clean water are key the world
food program says support for those in
nicaragua honduras and guatemala
will likely be needed until mid-2021
crystal commansing global news london
guardian rangers next tracking a rare
giraffe
the world's last known white giraffe has
a new accessory in an effort to keep it
safe
a gps device has been fitted on its horn
and it pings every hour
letting rangers track its path in a
kenya wildlife conservancy
a rare genetic trait caused this male
giraffe to be all white and it makes him
stand out dangerously on the savannah
poachers killed a white female and her
calf
back in march stronger animal welfare
laws could be coming to canada
a new bill has been proposed to ban
having apes and elephants
in captivity for entertainment it would
be just wonderful if this bill is passed
so that canada can prove that it is
on the forefront of humane treatment of
animals
the world's leading primatologist jane
goodall joined manitoba senator murray
sinclair to announce the jane goodall
act it would ban
zoos and other establishments from
acquiring new great apes or elephants
unless they're doing so for welfare or
conservation purposes
and it would ban imports of elephant
ivory and hunting trophies
would also ban private possession of big
cats like lions and tigers
senator sinclair was behind a bill that
passed last year banning
whales and dolphins in captivity in
canada
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with this beautiful sun halo
over the village of kit scotty alberta
thanks for watching
see you back here tomorrow take care of
yourselves bye bye
[Music]